- If that's your strategy for success,
the only thing that will
show up in your mailbox
is not the check, it's a
frickin' eviction notice.
If you can't sell, if you can't influence,
if you can't persuade,
good luck trying to get
your business off the ground.
And the only way to get
from conscious competence
to unconscious competence
is through practice.
Some people set goals that might be high,
but they're crappy goals.
Most people don't have a compelling vision
for their own future.
You got to get honest.
Don't blame the boss,
don't blame the leagues,
don't blame your job,
don't blame the industry you're in.
My message is this, there's
only one way to get rich,
and that's quick.
In the internal world,
before you can master
the external world, you have to master
your own internal world.
It's not how you actually perform
that earns you the respect of your peers.
It's the fact that you went
out and actually did it.
I live on love alone, really?
Go bring that to the bank and
pay the rent, hello, okay?
- He's an American author,
motivational speaker,
and former stockbroker.
- He published a memoir,
The Wolf of Wall Street,
which was adapted into a feature film.
- The main subject line of his seminars
is what he calls the Straight Line System.
- He's Jordan Belfort,
and here are his top 10 rules for success.
(dramatic music)
- I read this book,
because I was in disbelief,
'cause people would tell,
here's the strategy for success,
or the secret, right?
Go into your house, into a quiet room.
And you close the lights, draw the shades,
and sit on a couch and
visualize a big fat check.
25 Gs, thousand bucks
US, with your name on it.
And I want you to imagine that check,
and just make that check
go bigger in your mind,
and make it real, more real, and just,
put it out into the ether of the universe
and law of attraction will take hold.
Just think about it.
Bull (bleep), right?
Hello?
If that's your strategy for success,
the only thing that will
show up in your mailbox,
is not the check, it's the
frickin eviction notice
from your landlord.
They'll be towing away your car,
your wife, your husband be over
at the next-door neighbor,
and you'll be still
saying, "Where's the check,
"where's the check, where's?"
Okay?
The secret is a load of crap, okay?
Do I believe in manifestation?
Yeah, damn straight I do,
but you got to take action.
I'm one of those unfortunate people.
I tried it, I really
did, I swear I tried it.
I read the books, well
let me try it, you know?
So I sat down, I prayed for the check.
It never came.
But I went out and started
taking action, guess what?
The check came with an
extra couple of zeros.
And for like an entrepreneur,
not, forget a salesperson,
how about just an entrepreneur
who's looking to start a business.
Well, if you can't sell,
if you can't influence,
if you can't persuade, good luck trying
to get your business off the ground.
I'm not talking about just your customers.
I'm talking about the bankers,
the people of venture
capitalists, your vendors,
your credit card processor,
the people who work for you.
How do you get the people
to work for you excited?
How do you get them excited?
How do you get them to want
to buy into your vision?
At the highest level,
what sales really is,
is the transference of emotion.
And the emotion you're transferring
is this emotion of certainty.
That someone feels certain,
yeah it's a good thing,
it's going to help me,
it's going to fill my need.
When you're an entrepreneur
and you're trying to start a business,
and you're recruiting people,
well you're selling people on
your vision for the future,
your vision for this company.
And if you can't do that,
good luck trying to get
great people to work for you.
It's nearly impossible,
which is why you always see
the people they say,
"Oh, he's a visionary."
Well, that's true.
But typically not only
are they visionaries,
they also possess the ability
to sell the vision to other people,
to inspire them, to motivate them.
So selling is not just like
people think of selling,
"Oh, well I'm not a
salesman, I don't need the."
Well, yes you do.
You need to learn how to influence.
How about trying to get
your kids to make their bed,
or do their homework, or believe
in the value of education?
How about trying to get
a landlord to give you
a reduction on your rent,
or to extend the lease the way you want?
How about trying to negotiate terms?
You understand, it cuts to everything.
So, I always look at
this, say, you know what,
when I say I cracked
the code on influence,
what I really did essentially,
by working backwards almost,
by saying I'm going to start at the end
and go to the beginning,
see what has to happen
before someone says yes.
I was able to take that
and put it into this system
that took the no-name talentless guys,
and turned them into millionaires.
There are four levels of learning.
Okay, let me tell you what the levels are.
Some of you might now,
because you've been through
any self-development, this
is some very basic stuff,
but it's important here.
The first level is called being
unconsciously incompetent.
And what that means is this.
When you first start doing something
you know so little about it,
you basically know nothing.
You don't know what you don't know.
This is a very scary spot to be in,
when you're thrown into a situation
and you're a complete novice.
You say, "Jeez, I'd love
to get better at this,
"but I haven't the slightest
idea what I don't know."
Everyone follow that concept?
This is where most people start off, okay?
The next level is becoming
consciously incompetent.
That means that you're like,
"Jesus Christ, I don't know anything."
You're like, "There's this,
there's that, there's that,
"there's all these strategies.
"They all sound great.
"I don't know them."
That's the next level.
Next level above that is called
being consciously competent.
Consciously competent means
that you're good at something,
but you can't really do it
with your eyes closed yet.
You're good, but it
requires all your focus
and your mental energy.
Like, remember when we
were kids growing up,
learning to tie your shoe?
In the beginning, you're
like tie your shoe like.
You're puttinh your things across,
and someone says, "Excuse me."
You're like, "Don't interrupt me!"
You can't tie your shoe,
and have a conversation at the same time.
Right?
That's when you're consciously
competent in something.
It requires all your conscious focus.
The next level above that
is called being unconscious competence.
And that means when you're really, really
great at something, you can do
it without thinking about it.
And the only way to get
from conscious competence,
to unconscious competence
is through practice.
There's no other way.
By drilling it into your head,
again, and again, and again,
and again, and again, until
your brain just clicks,
and all of a sudden you're using
the unconscious part of your mind,
which is infinitely more powerful
than your conscious mind.
The reason that most
people are not successful,
or not wealthy, is not
because they set their goals
too high and miss them.
It's 'cause they set them
too low and hit them.
Get that?
It's not because you set
your goals too high and miss.
You set your goals too
low and you hit them.
And you get caught up in
the average daily struggle
of averages and mediocrity.
That's what kills people.
Everybody raise your hand
for a second, please.
Raise your hand.
Now raise it as high as you can.
I'm going to crouch so I can see, okay?
Now just raise it a bit
higher, everyone, higher.
Why the hell did that happen?
I say, "Raise it as high as you can."
And everyone says, "All right."
Then, "A little bit higher."
"Okay, well if you really mean it," right?
You get it?
It's that extra inch, that's
where you want to set your goal.
Not pie-in-the-sky and out of control,
like it's never going to happen.
'Cause that's a load of crap, too.
People that set those sort of goals,
they abandon those goals,
and we'll get to that later.
But the idea here is,
you want to set the goals
just above your comfort zone.
So now, think about it for a second.
Think about your goals right now.
How do you set 'em?
Are you setting them very
low and hitting them?
If that's the case,
then give yourself a 10.
Are you setting goals
that don't inspire you?
Some people set goals that might be high,
but they're crappy goals.
They're not the sort of
goals that make you jump
out of bed in the morning.
Make you want to go to work for yourself.
To secure the future, not just for you,
but for your family.
So you don't have to compromise
or acquiesce to anybody,
unless you love them, unless you want to.
That's freedom.
You know, money's just a
mechanism to get there.
Most people, and here's the
irony, is that most people
don't have a compelling
vision for their own future.
They don't.
They move through life setting goals,
and goals have no power.
Goals had power in 1959,
when Earl Nightingale came
to this idea of goal-setting,
and everyone was like,
"Wow, I'm a goal-oriented person."
And that was great, and it
worked for like 20 years.
Everyone set goals, and they got results.
But then all of a sudden,
you set goals, and sometimes
you hit them, sometimes you don't.
Most times you don't, and
that's okay, but goals almost
became a synonym for like,
"Oh, I'm going to set a goal,
"and who gives a (bleep) what
really happens afterwards."
It almost is synonymous with
failure now, goal-setting.
And I believe in setting
goals, but there's got to
be something above your goals.
And that's your vision for the future.
It doesn't have an ending point.
It's about the world being a certain way.
And that's inspiring to you.
When you truly have a
vision for your future
that inspires you, you're
going to jump up out of bed
in the morning, and feel
great about going at life,
versus being miserable, and
going to a job you hate,
or living a life that doesn't empower you,
and just every day moving
through just almost
like an automaton, not
really having the zest,
and the grit, and the greatness of life.
I'm guilty, I've been there
myself, when I felt like
I didn't really have a compelling
vision for my own future,
and I felt like I was wallowing.
But at least I'm conscious of that.
Once you become conscious of that,
you can consciously create
a vision for your future.
It doesn't happen in
one minute, or an hour.
You write it down, you work on it.
And when you finally hit on it,
you know how you know you got it?
When you read it back to
yourself, your vision statement,
and it moves you, and you feel inspired.
Okay, and so few people have that.
And what happens is every human being
is thirsty for a vision.
Everyone is.
And so few people have it.
And so what they do, they
gravitate toward someone
who has a vision for the future,
'cause they want to be a part of a vision.
Part of being a great entrepreneur
is having that vision,
being able to create the vision,
and then sell that vision to other people.
To get them to want to be
inspired, to buy into it.
To put in their time, their
hard work, their elbow grease,
to help you achieve your vision.
If you're a smart one, then
you spread the wealth around,
and it's a win-win for everybody.
The only thing that stops you
from getting what you want in life
is the bull (bleep)
story you tell yourself
of why you can't have it.
You get that?
What stops you back is the story,
because the story stops
you from getting honest.
And if you can't get honest with yourself,
there's nowhere you can go.
Imagine like this,
success in sales and life,
it's like a road map, right?
You know where you want to go,
and you have this perfect strategy
with a straight line to get there.
It's a perfect strategy.
It's going to get you
there every single time.
But if you don't know your starting point,
if you're not getting honest
with where you actually are,
it doesn't matter how
powerful the strategy is,
and it doesn't matter how
powerful your goal is.
I'm going to ask you to
set a goal today, right?
A 60 day goal.
And let's say you really set this goal,
and I'll show you how to
do it in a brilliant way,
so it's visceral, so it
makes you really feel it,
you see it, you sense
it, you smell the goal.
That's step one.
I'm going to teach you the straight line,
which is your strategy
to get to your goal.
But if you're not honest
with where you are right now,
your starting point, the map is worthless.
There's three things
that you need to know.
Where you are, where you want to go,
and how you're going to get there.
Those are the three things you must have
to take advantage of any opportunity.
I'm going to give you the strategy.
I'm going to ask you to tell me exactly
where you want to go, for yourself.
You got to get honest.
Don't blame the boss,
don't blame the leagues,
don't blame your job, don't
blame the industry you're in.
Just get honest.
If you don't like your
industry, find another one.
My message is this.
There's only one way to
get rich, and that's quick.
That's not a get rich
quick scheme, though.
Because the world's too
expensive to get rich slowly.
But what I mean by getting rich quick
is that there are certain
things you have to know.
On the inner game of wealth,
how you manage your emotional state,
your beliefs, your standards, your focus.
Then on the outer game,
entrepreneurship, sales, marketing,
how to develop multiple streams of income.
It takes time.
That's where the hard work,
'cause a lot of hard work
goes into getting this
lined up, and that lined up.
But once you have it all lined
up and you've done the work,
then you can make money
very, very quickly.
So it's not a scheme, but
you got to get rich quick,
and you have to put the work in.
I say, if you don't want
to work hard, good luck.
I don't know any rich people
that don't work really, really hard.
- Right, right, right.
- That's the bottom line.
So hard work and knowing stuff, skills.
- [Interviewer] There's
no quick fix, easy fix.
- No, again, when you get
rich, it happens quickly,
but there's a lot of work
that goes up to that point.
- [Interviewer] Goes into it, yes.
- Before the money starts pouring in.
That's the distinction that
I think a lot of people
who are not wealthy, they don't get that.
They think that you accumulate
money a little bit at a time,
it doesn't work that way.
You work, work, work, work,
don't get the result, bam,
one last piece of the puzzle clicks in,
whether it's not knowing how to close.
- [Interviewer] And it all happens.
- And it all happens quickly.
Also, to really take a longer term view.
Not just to look three months from now,
but look three years from now.
And the future's going to come,
whether you like it or not,
so you want to kind of be one step ahead.
- It's a mind game, then?
- Well, I think it's psychology.
Everything, again life, most of life,
comes down to psychology, doesn't it?
It starts here, in the internal world.
Before you can master the external world,
you have to master your
own internal world.
That's the true secret to success.
My son's 14, he's fabulous.
And we're having this conversation
about when he plays in sports,
or when he does something,
about do you go full out, or do you not.
And I see sometimes in him
that when he's out on the field
or doing something, he
doesn't play full out,
and will have an excuse.
Like, "My leg hurts," or "My arm hurts."
Or something happened,
the coach was unfair,
the referee was unfair.
And what happens with people
is we tend to go out into the world
and we look for those sort of excuses
about why things aren't
the way we want them.
And when you do that, you
lose all your power in life.
When you start focusing on the external,
on the excuses, you lose your power.
Here's the way people really think.
I will tell ya, I can go
out onto stage and bomb.
You go out there, and
you just bomb, right?
And people will respect
you for going out there
and trying your hardest.
It's not how you actually perform
that earns you the respect of your peers.
It's the fact that you went
out and actually did it.
That's the difference.
So if you're out there right now,
and you're a new salesperson,
or you're struggling as a salesperson,
there's no embarrassment in struggle.
There's just not.
The embarrassment is in quitting.
The embarrassment is in
not trying your hardest.
Poor people believe they are
creatures of circumstance.
That means that life happens to them.
You get that?
While rich people are
creators of circumstance.
I will tell you this.
There is no more destructive
belief in the world
than to think that life happens to you.
'Cause there's three things that you do
when you don't think you
can create your own destiny.
I'll tell you exactly
what they are, ready?
Number one.
The first thing you do is you play
what I call the blame game.
You start blaming everybody
for why you don't have what you want.
You'll blame the government,
you'll blame your family,
you'll blame your spouse,
you'll blame your boss,
you'll blame the economy,
you'll blame the people
on Wall Street, which
probably deserves some blame.
But you'll blame anybody and everybody
when you think the world happens to you.
You're powerless.
The second thing you do, is you justify.
It is because, because the economy stinks.
It's because people are unfair to me.
It's because money doesn't
really matter anyway.
Bull (bleep), you don't know that.
"I live on love alone," really?
Go bring that to the bank and
pay the rent, hello, okay?
I love love, I'm in love,
I'm with the greatest woman in the world.
I'm going to get married next year.
For the third time, unfortunately,
but I'm getting married next year.
Great woman.
So I know that money's money, right?
They justify.
Third.
This is the worst one of all.
So write it down in big
letters, they complain.
I hate these people, you know why?
I'll tell you why.
'Cause I do believe in some
laws of the universe, I do.
And one of them is that what you focus on
expands, gets bigger.
And what you focus on, you attract,
because you move towards it.
You're focusing on something, you attract.
So here's what happens.
When you're complaining,
what are you focusing on?
All the (bleep) in your life.
So guess what happens to you?
You become a giant (bleep) magnet.
(audience laughs)
Get the picture?
I don't want to be around
because they attract it to you.
You got to get away from them.
Because when you hear some complaining,
it might hit you too,
and it's the worst of all.
That's what complaining does.
So if you're a person that believes
that you're a creature of circumstance,
life happens to you, good luck.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
- We made this video because
Vlad Vasiliev asked us to.
If you have a famous entrepreneur
or a very special person
you'd like this guy to make a video of,
leave it in the comments below.
- I'd also love to know
which of the top 10 rules
you heard today meant the most to you.
Leave in the comments
or join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and we'll see you soon.
- Mm-hm, we will.